hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game from round four of the
2018 candidates tournament here between
Alexander district and the Dingley rain
and so far the first four rounds have
been extremely exciting a lot of
interesting games and the amount of
interesting games is actually beyond my
expectations as these are the candidates
I thought the games would be a lot more
boring and props go - definitely -
Dingley rain as he's now after four
rounds he's only at 50% but he did have
three games with the black pieces so far
and only one game with white so having
50% in a field like this it's quite an
amazing result and he's never afraid to
go into any crazy variation this game
here if I didn't tell you it was played
by Griff shook and England in the
candidates you'd think it was after the
first one he moves maybe a bullet game
or horribly the game but it's quite
interesting and you'll see what I mean
by this and it's one of the rare cases
on the highest level where you'll see a
case of double chest blindness so let's
see the game grease Chuck has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 and Knight to f3 the
antonyms Oh Indian Knight this sorry d5
we transpose into the Queens gambit
declined and now Knight to c3
we have c6 the semi Slav and the Bishop
to g5 h6 Bishop to h4 and now D captures
on c4 agree shoe goes for efore we have
g5 attacking the bishop bishop to g3 and
now b5 here Bishop to e2 by grace choke
and here
ding leerin plays Bishop to b7 idea like
b4 is also possible dislodging this
night to win d4 pawn but after night a4
and Knight captures only for white we'll
get a lot of development after this
Bishop to g5 move knight has to go back
and now White has a wide variety of
options he can either win the pawn back
immediately he can choose to develop
rook c1 he can castle he can even decide
to go crazy in push h4 so a lot of
options here and ding Liron obviously
isn't interested in playing something
like this
so after Bishop to e2 Bishop to b7 and
here grigio castles Knight B to d7 and
now comes Knight to e5 we have Bishop to
g7 and here at England is basically
basically forcing Greece Chuck
to do his next move as I don't think
this next move by Alicia came as a
surprise to him here a Grisha plays
Knight captures on f7 with a very simple
but strong idea King captures on f7 and
now II five dislodging this night from
f6 and creating a wonderful outpost for
the night
first on e4 and then on d6 so Knight to
d5
we had Knight to e4 Queen to b6 and now
Knight to d6 check King moves and now a
for immediately trying to bust open the
Queen side to be able to attack the long
King Ghani salmon as a Greece should
basically sacrificed one night to create
to evolve this Knight into a monster
night on d6 as you can see how many
important squares this this Knight is
covering it's like it's a complete
monster so a four we have rook a to f8
and now Bishop to f3 Grisha wants to get
rid of all earrings powerful knight on
d5 as well so a 6
we have Bishop captures on d5 C captures
on d5 and a capture some b5 a capture
some b5 and now came to h1 Grichuk wants
to execute f4 but he doesn't want his
King to be and and thus Queen's diagonal
as it could bring him some problems so
Bishop to c6 black doesn't really have a
useful move here and now grace rook
executes his f4 move and this is
definitely the critical moment of the
game this has only moved to anyone but
this is where the game is being decided
here you don't want to do anything with
this pawn you want to push h5
start your own attack on the White King
or you want to improve the position of
your own King to bring him to some
safety but here dinkler and played G
captures on f4 and this move loses the
game on the spot now
shook about Ganesha can deliver and
didn't see this so if by any chance you
haven't seen this game pause the video
and try to find the winning continuation
for Greece joke I will give it a couple
of seconds as usual so for those of you
who were able to find that
congratulations both Grisha can deliver
and weren't able to find it and if you
just want to enjoy the show the move
Greece shook missed here is Bishop to h4
check why is this source so powerful is
if as you can see at the bishop is
covering all of the dark squares around
the king the knight is covering the
light squares so the King doesn't have
anywhere to go now you have to block
this obviously we wanna block it with
the bishop for the night you don't want
to block it with the rook and now if you
walk it with the bishop then comes Queen
to g4 and again what do you do here if
you you can't capture the bishop if you
capture it then you get win to g7 but
you can play rook to g8 attacking the
Queen but now comes it captures on f6
with check King captures Knight & e6 but
now Queen captures on F forward to check
and again the King has nowhere to go all
of the dark squares are covered and the
light light squares are occupied by
pieces and pawns
so here black would have to push a 5 but
now simply D captures an e5 would check
King moves and now e 6 comes with the
attack on the knight King to b7 as the
King was in check and now even f7 now
both the rockin g8 is attack the knight
and d7 is attacked and after black does
any move every move loses for black here
let's say d4 trying to create some
chances attacking the g2 pawn here
simply F captures an g8 bring you a
queen into the game rook captures and
now Bishop to g3 and black is lost you
either lose this night or you move the
knight Queen to f7 Czech picks up the
rook it's all over from black on the
other hand after this G captures on f4
move and Bishop to h4 check you could
also block put the night but this isn't
this isn't really better your idea is of
course
pawn captures and then King captures not
but again Queen to g4
the knight is pinned
and here what do you do the bishop on g7
is now attacked you have to defend it
rook the g8 but now comes Queen captures
on f4 and again you're really without a
move here you're your king your knight
is pinned you have to move the King and
after King to d7 e captures on f6 you
capture and here you can simply sorry
capture with the bishop rook attacks
bishop and now you simply play Queen to
e5 all of your pieces are defended
you're winning this game
black etre like doesn't really have a
choice here he would have to capture
rook captures rook captures rook
captures rook captures and after Knight
captures now comes Queen to e5 check
King has to move and now rook to a 7
wins the game you either move the king
and then Queen to h8 will be decisive or
you capture it and then Queen g7 wins
the Queen after the King moves so this
was the critical moment of the game of
21 the game could have been over at this
point but grief shock played rook
captures on f4 obviously his home
preparation didn't stretch this far into
the game here rook captures on f4 Bishop
captures on f4 and now the bishop the
bishop is no longer able to deliver
check King to d8 England immediately
transfer see transfers his King to
safety we have King - gee Quinn - g4 and
now rook to f8 we have Bishop to d2
getting the rock out of the way of
course you don't want to allow Queen
captures and rook captures on f4 so
getting the bishop to safety and now
King to c7 and here white again has a
wide variety of options a king to c7 was
actually the strongest move for black
and it's amazing how the England finds
it because you have to be careful of
this Bishop to a5 idea losing the Queen
of course at the moment this is
impossible if the Bishop to a5 Queen
simply captures it and after rook
captures rook to f1 this is checkmate
another thing to consider is what about
Queen captures on g7 you could do this
but after Queen captures then Queen
captures on d4 attacking the bishop
attacking the b2 pawn so Bishop to a5
check King moves and now what do you do
here your B to pawn is attacked
black
threatening to infiltrate the
second-ranked with the rook so after you
bring the Queen back to the defense now
simply Queen kept for some b2 attacking
the rook Queen to e1 defending and now
Queen captures on e5 you literally
destroyed all of white spawns and you're
winning this game easily so after this
King to c7 move Grisha plays h3 now now
there's no more look to f1 checkmating
ideas and now Bishop to a5 definitely is
a threat so now the Engler and stops at
b4 we have Queen captures on g7
analogous is possible but now Queen
captures on d4 again attacking the
bishop on d2 Bishop captures on before
and now Queen captures on b2 again
attacking the bishop and also the rook
on a1 here
Bishop to a5 check you do have to move
the bishop would attempt Oh King moves
to be 8 and now rope the g1 rope to g1
is the best move as you don't want to
put it to us put the rook on a silly
square to allow the Queen to Riemann
over herself using the attacks and on
the rook so rook to g1 and now c3 and
what do you do here here again you have
to be very careful it's a very delicate
position
you can't afford to grab up on with the
Queen for example Queen captures on h6
then c2 comes and this brings a lot of
trouble to white d5 pawn is attacked and
you have to do something
Queen g5 and now comes d4 this deep one
is also starting to roll down the board
and now we've opened up the attack from
the bishop to the g2 upon a very nice
position for black most likely winning
so after this C to remove grease you've
decided to play Queen to e7 and grab the
H pawn in a different way here King Lear
and played c2 threatening c1 promoting
to a queen and now Bishop to d2
defending c1 and also attacked in the h6
pawn queen to eat Queen captures on if I
was played and now Bishop captures and
h6 Rock to g8
a getting drugged out of the attack now
comes Knight to f7 attacking the Queen
and here again a very interesting
position a lot of things are possible
you can see that the rock is on the g2
point the bishop could also be eyeing
the g2
upon but ideas like d4 unfortunately
aren't possible with the idea of
sacrificing the Queen and then capturing
because after you capture this doesn't
really achieve anything with the idea
that if rook captures you promote to a
queen because now Knight c99 captures on
c6 is delivered way to check but on the
other side Queen Queen to d6 also leads
the checkmate for white so after night
to f7 we have Queen to c3 getting the
Queen already attack we have Queen to d6
check King to be 7 and now Queen
captures on e6 and here at England plays
d4 this starts this D pawns journey and
also now opens up a very important
attack on the g2 pond and well this is
this is a very strong move even stronger
would be rook to e8 as Greece Chuck will
very skillfully use this undefended rook
on g8 to remain over his pieces but okay
d4
now we have Knight to d6 check King
moves and now Knight to e4 attacking the
Queen on c3 and also now the queen is
attacking the rock on g8 and here
Dingley encounters with Knights the c5
offering the exchange of nights but also
attack English troops Queen on e6 so
what do you do here you can't really
afford to exchange Queens if Knight
captures Knight captures this endgame is
completely lost for white so after night
c5 Queen captures and g8 the best move
for good is to grabbing the rook and now
comes Knight captures on e4 so after all
of this
both sides have two points and now
Grisha is actually up the exchange but
it doesn't really matter much those
passed pawns of Dingley rents are so far
down the board and there are all sorts
of tricks here involved Grisha has to be
very careful as if this night for
example ever moves from me for Queen
captures on a check on h3 would be
checkmate as the g2 pawn is pinned so
King H to immediately biding clear and
not allowing any any such tricks to even
exist
d3 a story by grace choke now d3 biding
Liron and now Bishop to e3 would check
King to b5 and Queen
to be eight again with check and now
it's a question Ken Dingley run escape
checks and grab a full point in this
game or will grease should be able to
continue checking him so King to see for
now Queen to see seven threatening to
capture the bishop on c6 Queen to f6
defending the bishop and now rook to f1
our final a final try by Alexander
grease chip to win this game now if you
grab the rook after Queen captures now
Queen captures Bishop with check and the
bishop and the Queen are creating a wall
the black King cannot defend the knight
on e4
so after King moves Queen captures and
now this is hard to say if it's winning
but probably it is yeah it's probably
winning for white as there is no way to
promote any of these pawns you don't
really gain anything by by winning the
bishop as White has two points and you
will be left with only one point
so after this rook to F one Queen to d6
now the England forces a trade of
Queen's Queen captures Knight captures
and rook to F rook to f6 attacking both
deny the night can't move because the
bishop is hanging King to d5 and now the
only move that actually saves the game
for Greece shock is Rock captures and
these sex you have to give back the
exchange because if if the England
species become active those past points
are simply too strong so King characters
now it's an opposite colored bishop
endgame and it's a completely wrong
drawn position
a couple of more moves were played the
g3 King the five King f2 came to see for
Bishop to d2 now came to be three and
now came to e3 grigio forces g2 pawn
unfortunately for grizzle you can't
afford to put to start pushing any of
the pawns but even if you could I mean
it wouldn't matter because of King b2 if
you allow this game to occupy the B 2
square covering c1 then black is winning
so after King we three kings to e3 and
now comes Bishop captures on g2 and
after this special characters on g2 the
a draw was agreed upon but it doesn't
matter even if you play something like
King be too kinky
after 73 so fairly simple you can't make
any progress here Bishop captures
h4 Bishop f3 the black pawn can never
promote and the white pawn can never
cross a light square so yeah after
Bishop captures on g2 they agreed to a
draw but I mean water game and it's very
exciting I mean this this here moment
that we said after G captures on f4 so
move 21 the game could have ended and
move 21 if Bishop if Grisha found Bishop
to h4 check but yeah he didn't a case of
double blindness in top-level chess and
not a very often thing to see but it
happens I do hope you enjoyed it and for
for the end of this video a couple of
photos as we do have some photos from
the candidates here we have this song
around the opening from the game you can
see that Gary shook is ready to battle
Dingley and also very interested in the
game here we have another move another
photo where the England makes a move and
here we even have a nice photo from the
interview after the game probably
probably the moment where Greece Chuck
realizes what he did by missing that
Bishop to h4 move Karla which shows it
to him and you can see by the England's
face that you know he's very satisfied
with himself but yeah he dodged a bullet
there but after that I mean it was a
case of double blindness he played an
excellent game and really calculated
everything so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it once again I would
like to thank Nicky Riga for her photos
from the candidates all of her links to
her social media pages are in the
description below so feel free to follow
her as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
depending on if there will be any
interest in games in the candidates or
if not I will continue my table tunics
series thank you all and I will see you
soon